[Music]
and welcome back to
hot seat well we've got the hottest seat
with even hotter questions featuring our
boys
hey
yo i feel like i'm at chuck e cheese in
this goddamn chair right now
god dude that's a real throne you're
sick dude this is oh sorry throne sorry
oh man
he just talked about this before the
camera started it's made by the mayor of
monterey park the mayor of the city that
you're in right now he made that for him
yeah he did buy his bare hands for what
he's a big fan that's what we want him
out
hot seat
the hardest with even harder questions
okay so we'd like to start the hot seat
off really really cold and really really
good yeah the number one cold dry guy in
the world is bart so he's just dragged
out
and these are questions for me yeah yeah
to get to know you yeah okay oh yeah to
get to know you like never before okay
so the first question is
what's your favorite tree who favorite
tree
oak
are you like oh why do you like oak uh
because that was the first thing i
thought of
can you great answer honest guy
that's great can you describe what
oaks like and compare it to another tree
uh
uh it has a lot of strength like redwood
i see subscribers dipping away
hey bart can you send us a video a
playlist of all the videos that you
watch so i can throw in the [ __ ]
trash
i know what did did i say something
about trees in an interview or something
no this is just bart's mind oh okay
this is the first question bartlett is a
tree podcast
[Laughter]
all right let's slowly warm it up when
was the last time you cried last time i
cried
damn
uh
i'm a robot so
yeah we don't cry damn last time i
caught what about in movies you don't
cry movies oh oh oh you know what
every time i watch this [ __ ] movie
and i watched it and the first uh and i
watched it on the plane for the first
time because i just downloaded it was
pursuit of happiness oh yeah and that
part where he gets the job every [ __ ]
time and i and i didn't think i was like
man i've seen it so many times i was
like i'm not gonna cry and i'm on the
plane bawling and i'm like i've already
seen this [ __ ] movie airplanes
we've also kind of talked about this but
father-son dynamics [ __ ] hits
oh yes
do you have that stutter breath
yeah i was sitting here like it's like
my my
[ __ ] starts to like you know
like flutter or whatever whatever you
call it it starts doing that and i'm
like oh [ __ ] here it goes there you go
did you see that
yeah
the extended edition of pursuit of
happiness where will smith starts
attacking street comedians
there's like a guy to a blue and a blue
animal and he starts [ __ ] just
waiting on the guys
that was a good question [ __ ] those
trees man yeah
bart ask another question quick
go bart
so you said that you grew up in phoenix
arizona uh yeah specifically mesa mesa
yeah how was that like how was how was
that like like like growing up out there
um
it's arizona's kind of like it's boring
out there so you got to create like
kind of create your own fun and a lot of
people just do [ __ ] like skateboarding
was the thing for me uh playing guitar
you know all these other things and
obviously cheerleading you know that's
the [ __ ] that i like
you know really starting arizona not
kentucky no that started arizona okay
are you an arizona cardinals fan
i didn't don't i don't really care
there you go hey there you go
you didn't get the game you ever watched
a super bowl like this
just at home [ __ ] turn away
that's what you're used to yeah that's
what i used to do
but i could hear everything yeah that's
cool
what's your first down first step
so you said you got adopted by a white
family when you're 16. uh yeah my teens
yeah roughly how did that happen oh that
whole thing um you know rich like i said
originally i was with my biological mom
and my stepfather but stepfather was
crazy and abusive and then this family i
already knew the family and they just
took me in
oh wow how did you know were they like
your friends or relatives i actually
owned the cheerleading gym that i
cheered at whoa
yeah yeah so that's how i met them
so that's why cheerleading is such a
it's like a
thing for you oh yeah in many many ways
it saved my life what's that
conversation with your mom like because
you're like yo i want to go with these
people no it wasn't he wasn't even that
my stepfather had kicked me out oh [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah he didn't it
was funny because he uh
he was
because he thought i wasn't going to
survive i was like [ __ ] i got this
i know white people don't
i'll be white people you know how many
white people you [ __ ] know
i was like i got white people on my side
no
so i actually wasn't i i was actually
super thrilled that he had kicked me out
because he uh he kicked me out
he tried he tried to tell me to pack my
[ __ ] and then he's i remember he slapped
my bag out of my hand it was like he's
like you ain't going nowhere with your
simple ass and i was like man i got
plenty of places to go you know i was
all [ __ ] flossing and [ __ ]
and then when i said that he got like
superheated
you know started like swinging at me i
was like [ __ ] i got this now you know
what i'm saying like i know i know your
[ __ ] moves dog and then so
so i ran out of the house and ran to his
his mom
um which i considered her my grandma uh
lived across the street and so i rented
her house was like yo go get him cause
he was terrified of her everyone oh
really yeah he was terrified of her and
then she i think she just over the years
like she just got exhausted she was
getting older
and then eventually kicked me out and i
was like [ __ ] yes i was like pursuit
of happiness like will smith just
[ __ ]
when he gets the job
[Laughter]
oddly enough my stepfather and i were
actually cool now yeah yeah we're
actually cool now yeah yeah so how does
that happen how did that work yeah
you know i started when i started on the
when i started doing jokes
about about him and i noticed
[Laughter]
i noticed when i would do the jokes
um it sounded like i was upset
and i was like man why i said why is
this joke not working
and you know just being a comedian
trying to like really work out the [ __ ]
i was like oh i sound like i'm mad i
sound like i'm still like upset like it
doesn't sound so it's uncomfortable for
the audience oh you can't get on board
with like drama not like you're laughing
at it and then what i did is i went like
all the way back and basically
understood all this [ __ ] and i had to
understand him which i didn't which i
never took the time to do that's crazy
so once i understood his story
then it was easy for me to transition
and be like cool with them
once you understood his story where
you're like oh that's why i got kicked
out yeah yeah i was like oh damn yeah no
yeah i understood everything like
and
honestly
this may weird be weird for you know for
people to hear but yeah i don't i don't
take any of it all that [ __ ] that
happened i don't take it personal
yeah because it was just like oh that
[ __ ] that no i'm not trying to justify
what he did or like you know henderson
i'm not trying to like i thought you
were sorry
you're about to walk out
i felt it you were like hey
hey you're gonna change room change
so you're an advocate for step violence
stepmother violence yeah yeah
no in a lot of ways you know and i do
have to give them credit because i i
learned a lot of things that i
you know
i mean just how to be comfortable with
myself and as an individual
uh to understand that everybody has a
story everybody comes from something
crazy
some people don't figure it out some
people do
i feel blessed to be able to figure out
so why should i be mad at him wow that's
awesome man yeah speaking of mad we're
at the 8 minute 27 second mark of the
video this is usually when we start
turning up the heat and stuff so you
keep on so how bad did he beat you
just what kind of combination what kind
of
[Laughter]
but you did mention anger management a
lot what was like the most uh
angry experience that like triggered it
so you had to go to
a lot of them
okay what's the most [ __ ] up thing you
did
oh i when i yeah i tried to fight my
teachers whoa yeah i tried to fight like
a bunch of teachers like in high school
yeah high school yeah that was a guy i
went to anger management three times the
third time worked third time working
what is it uh
is it a program or like you go to a
class or is it like rehab
yeah yeah and then since you like
basically having like one-on-one
sessions
with uh a person that is a professional
and helping people deal with anger was
it a different person each time yeah
each time i went yeah and uh yeah the
first you beat up the first two and then
i actually i actually [ __ ] missed i
missed it
i swung so many [ __ ] times and missed
every single one where were you fighting
boxers
[Laughter]
she's like [ __ ] i got you i got you
figured out
i see that swing coming
yeah
today's video is brought to you by
expressvpn when do we decide to stop up
holding free speech as a basic human
right what's playing out right now at
the big tech companies and social media
sites sets a dangerous precedent look it
doesn't matter what your politics are or
who you voted for everyone should have
the right to express themselves freely
sadly the big tech monopoly has opted
instead for silencing tactics and
censorship to fight back against big
text control of the internet i use
expressvpn ever wondered how free to
access tech giants make all their money
well
it's by tracking your searches video
history and everything that you click on
by building a profile on you and then
selling off your sensitive data when you
use the expressvpn app on your computer
or phone you anonymize your online
presence by hiding your ip address that
makes your activity much more difficult
to trace and sell to those advertisers
what's more
expressvpn encrypts a hundred percent of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals what i
like most is how easy it is to use it
just takes one click to protect all of
your devices that's why expressvpn is
rated number one by business insider so
let's stop allowing big tech to revoke
our rights to free speech why not revoke
their right to your data instead secure
your internet with the vpn i trust for
online protection visit
expressvpn.com off the record that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash off the record to get
three extra months free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
off the record right now to go learn
more [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah when you hear
about people acting out now like
obviously you have a much different
perspective because most people they'll
see that on the news and just go what a
little [ __ ] ruffian or whatever
but for you you're like oh i i see their
trauma this is coming from oh yeah yeah
you can see the trauma totally totally
like anytime like
anyone i i just it like immediately just
i know exactly where it comes from you
know based off of the knowledge that
i've gained
uh i don't like not specific detail
where it comes from it's like oh they
have some past [ __ ] they they haven't
[ __ ]
uh worked out yet you could just tell
what do you think worked for the uh at
the third time when you went like what
uh the third time um
i think what worked was the fact that he
took things uh shout out to chip
he took things about me
and basically use those tools
to help me with my anger like it was a
different person each time yeah it was a
different person each time and
i think with chip like he he knew i was
a fan of
punk rock music punk rock and hardcore
music and so he based in he knew i was a
fan of henry rollins you know like
that's who i idolized and so basically
he took things about henry and was
because henry
was like an angry dude as well but he
goes but look what he's doing now you
know where he transitioned his anger and
they also help me understand that like
my anger would never leave you know i
think the earlier stages of anger
management i think they were just like
you're angry trying to suppress you yeah
yeah exactly and they were trying to
like like get rid of it but no anger's a
thing that everybody [ __ ] have i load
it up on my ball so i can shoot it out
through my dick yeah yeah
it's pretty effective too yeah some
people say yeah some say joe has a
problem yeah
we need to meet up with chips
you need to meet up with chip though
yeah
so were you in your management when you
were with uh your white parents
uh yes i was uh but the third time was
when i was cheering in college in texas
you know wow the anger management went
all the way into college yeah i tried to
beat up someone on the on my team
were they asking for it though oh yeah
what's she asking is she asking
[Laughter]
what does she do
when i think of cheerleaders jenna do i
know there's guys on the team but
whenever you say cheerleaders i see you
in like
10 blonde hotties petite hotties yeah
and he's just launching them dude no
naughties at all no knives allowed
just and you're just being a [ __ ]
drill sergeant to all these girls
yeah that was that was my life but yeah
the third time was that yeah was in
college
when you're in a club like that because
dude i was in in the improv community
and everyone's just [ __ ] each other
yeah are you guys just pounding away at
each other
yeah these questions aren't really
turning up yeah uh
i'll explain like this like okay so
being a straight dude my subconscious
nod yeah
uh because i'm not really a [ __ ] kiss
and tell kind of person but
being a straight man
and cheerleading is the best
and
like you got to think
you're around especially if you're good
especially if you're good they look up
to you yeah and then also like you got
to realize
there's there's a lot of gay dudes
there's more gay dudes on the [ __ ]
team than straight dudes
so it's like you're in a win-win
situation good numbers yeah good ratio
situation everyone loves you yeah yes
yes so would you say like let's say you
go into high school and you're trying to
get laid it's better to be a cheerleader
than a football player
um
you have all the information just answer
that
because i heard that being a male
nursing student is better like if you
suck if you suck in football ain't no
girl looking at you but if you suck at
cheerleading straight yeah but what if a
girl doesn't know football and she
doesn't know that you suck at football
she knows you're on the team you just
see the jersey crowd reaction crowd
reaction
oh okay because they talk yeah crowd
reaction yeah they can see yeah
okay so
you have been through a lot of things
yeah and you uh including cheerleaders
[Laughter]
russian books
i [ __ ] see it on his face
and you have you have a a very very
composed head on your shoulders where
you can like make up with like you know
your stepfather you can like not have
like remorse or things or take things
personally
out of everything that you've been
through like what is like the most maybe
potentially regrettable moment uh in
your life no i don't have any regrets
because if i did i then i didn't learn
anything
see and that's the end of the video do
you you know what the the anger that you
feel um now it seems like you're very
under control with it with all of it is
there a healthy way that you
because like those feelings don't leave
is there like a healthy way that you
channel it or a productive way that you
challenge so as you're like are you like
dexter like are you like doing a serial
murder somewhere no no just people don't
just smile through just calmly oh wait
say it wait what was the question did
you express the anger
oh where does it go yeah you know oh
into my journaling my journaling uh
so
the anger goes towards like
all the things i love to do you know but
like it's i take the anger energy
not necessarily like the
intensity of like just like being angry
i take the energy of anger and basically
transition that into
you know just kicking ass at the things
i do that i love it what pisses you off
the most in the world
that's trying to make a bakery yeah uh
the one the one thing that pisses me off
more in the world is when uh
someone when people try to define other
people like because i think at the end
of the day man you got to give a person
a chance to be able to define themselves
and i think a lot of times people want
to sit there and they want to define
another person and who they are and i
don't think that's necessarily fair
because it's basically judgment yeah
basically judgment but it's like you
know people were like oh this person did
this because they're this this this and
this and it's like hey let them let them
learn their story let them learn you
know let them figure themselves out you
know and and don't don't sit and like
define yourself more why don't you learn
about
you you know what i mean instead of just
like like i think it's weird when people
try to like
pay attention especially if it's someone
they don't like
you know what i mean or someone that
like frustrates them so they make them a
villain yeah so they make it they want
this person to be like a villain like
anything that person says they just try
to make this person like just toxic and
hey meanwhile that person may have some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] about them but it's like
hey let them [ __ ] at least have a
chance to define themselves and
understand themselves and be able to
[ __ ] grow from whatever they're
trying to grow from i agree with you
except for furries i think they're
[ __ ] weird furries
yeah that's the only one group i'm like
nah i'm writing you off forever i don't
know i don't want to know but judgment
on them
i'm curious about stopping by one of
those furry expos though they look crazy
pretty that's why i don't want to go
because i'm afraid i like it
i'm gonna end it with one last question
yeah um we all know you're a stand-up
comedian and let's say you get it to the
next level
and once you get that phone call that
you made it to the next level
which set of parents do you call first
to celebrate with logical or your
adoption oh it's like i don't know i
don't know i don't really call anyone
for anything because i don't i don't
necessarily get excited about
stuff like that as much as i just get
excited about doing the thing that i
like to do
i'm a weird [ __ ] guy when it comes to
that [ __ ] because um well which
thanksgiving dinner do you go home to
first oh i don't go i don't do that at
all yeah yeah [ __ ] it all yeah all at
all no are you still close with your
adopted oh yeah i'm close with all of
them but they they understand they
always they say this they say the same
thing every year they go we already know
the answer
but
you're invited
because yeah i'll just yeah i don't
really white parents are the best man
yeah
but it's like
dude everybody needs some white parents
dude everyone needs someone oh if i
don't go my parents are [ __ ] on me
dude i'm gonna get some white parents
yeah i'm gonna get i'ma i'm gonna get
there wait what
he's 38 years old he's trying to get
white
[Music]
you